les gens ne se bousculent pas pour
travailler dans les champs et la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre est un enjeu bien
réelle en agriculture on cherche
désespérément des travailleurs pourtant
en montérégie des producteurs maraîchers
bible histoire inverse des travailleurs
de l'autre bout du monde ont choisi leur
ferme et sont venus les épaules et deux
jeunes garçons rentre de l'école l'un
d'eux sakrouhi qaîda n'a pas grandi à
mont-saint-grégoire mais dans un
archipel à des milliers de kilomètres
d'ici là dans la cuisine
yoshi sa mère prépare le repas pendant
que madoka sa petite soeur joue
tranquillement plus loin dans les champs
son père tatsuya travaillent la terre
quand on l'invité au japon on avait une
femme comme un site propre au fameux
marché biologique
[Musique]
dans la région de nagano tatuya ishii
louer un lopin de terre où ils
cultivaient des légumes et des fleurs
comestibles au bout de dix ans mon
propre et on m'a dit que niveau le pas
le nom de m il note au contrat qu'il
fallait quitter cette éviction sera
l'élément déclencheur on a beaucoup
d'effets si notre futur j'ai pensé que
oui maintenant on part à l'étranger pour
faire une autre expérience pour moi est
que la famille
il lance alors une sorte de bouteilles à
la mer version moderne
j'ai écrit une lettre à une quinzaine de
fermes dans le monde entier en disant on
est prêt à quitter le japon on voudrait
s'établir dans une ferme bio dynamique
pour moins pour quelques années des leds
en bon français avec des belles photos
de la famille de yoshi tatsu ya deux
japon puis disait qu'ils étaient
intéressés avaient travaillé chez nous
ça fait zéro on les rapaces il faut
qu'ils viennent chez nous
la firme cadet rousselle que gère arnaud
maillet et anne roussel suit les
principes de la biodynamie
cette approche complexe se base entre
autres sur les cycles de la lune pour
déterminer le moment opportun pour semer
et récolter s'y trouvaient des employés
en agriculture est ardu recruter des
gens spécialisés en biodynamie relève de
l'exploit biodynamie c'est très rare qu
pour avoir le permis de travail ce plus
facile qu'ailleurs une spécialité où
quelque chose qui on peut dire ben oui
on reçoit des demandes de gens qui
veulent venir travailler mais en
biodynamie c'est vraiment rare
la ferme approvisionne 600 familles
durant la haute saison
elle emploie une dizaine de travailleurs
dont quelques mexicains et un
guatémaltèque printemps dans une
démarche que la firme a une grosse pour
deux personnes à réfléchir à tout ce qui
à réfléchir avec savoir mid annonce de
recherche on était en recherche de déjà
avec qui partager le quotidien partager
les soucis partager leurs trois cols et
les décisions à prendre
[Musique]
depuis 2019 les ikeda sont partie
prenante des opérations de la ferme
mais si tu as tu y as était décidé à
quitter le japon
sa famille o'shea n'était pas aussi
convaincu sa première visite a lieu en
plein hiver première fois pour deux
semaines
pour moi c'était pas de te sûr de venir
ici encore pour vivre avec des enfants
étaient encore fermés parce qu'il fait
froid c'est aussi deux n'est pas ou deux
images de la ferme parce que c'était
avec les neiges
finalement c'est pour ces enfants
qu'elle décidera de faire le grand saut
pour qu'ils puissent apprendre une autre
langue et évoluer dans un cadre scolaire
moins stricte qu'au japon l'ambiance
d'éducation c'est un peu différent il
n'y a pas beaucoup de devoirs non plus
au japon c'est la pause
mais les enfants il faut passer le
moment des enfants pour moi je pense il
y a plus les choses important que de
boire
[Musique]
une fois arrivé c'est l'adaptation même
si le couple avait déjà séjourné en
france à quelques reprises la langue
française demeure pour eux plein de
subtilités dont on parlait d'un chandail
avec de l'ail puis un chandail au tchad
mais c'est le même mot je dirais ces
deux mots chandail mais un mot champ
d'action et au delà des mots il y à tous
le non-dit et la manière de dire les
choses qui sont différents au japon un
défi de communication c'est ça le plus
gros défi contre pour moi c'est il faut
avoir beaucoup de décollage aussi oui
c'est pas toujours facile pour moi
et le fossé n'est pas que culturel il
est aussi agricole les saisons ne sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes et les
superficies non plus dans son pays
tatsuya cultivait tout seul une parcelle
d'un hectare
en comparaison la firme cadet rousselle
compte cinq hectares de légumes
diffusait déjà de l'agriculture à petite
échelle puis finalement pas ici il
trouve qu'on fait de l'agriculture à
grande échelle par rapport à ce que lui
faisait au japon l'ultra ya beaucoup à
la main ces deux là des choses que des
fonds il commence à la maison de l'outil
pour cela blessure kaboom de coûts
tracteur ses fesses de rock et s'est
fixé comme des faux faux coming up ce
plus sur la méthode de culture mais en
général les taux se sont deuxième et et
puis il y est un poisson dans l'eau
l'heure c'est ce sens mais thil
toutefois que sa passion qui est plus
dur à arrêter cas d'e.coli jeudi
après-midi dans le quartier
notre-dame-de-grâce à montréal ces jours
de livraison des paniers
[Musique]
comme bien des petits producteurs
maraîchers
tatsuya doit maîtriser de multiples
tâches il supervise les champs et
veillent aussi à la distribution des
légumes
yoshi elle est responsable de nourrir sa
mise et travailleurs au quotidien
aujourd'hui au menu un gratin de pommes
de terre et de choux fleurs avec des
légumes de la ferme évidemment les
mélanges et de légumes de saison et
d'essayer de conduire est aussi il faut
avoir de la place pour prochain légumes
l'agriculture biodynamique demande
d'être très à l'écouté de la nature
la présence au chant est donc essentiel
un rôle qui sied bien
tatsuya passe beaucoup de temps à
observer prévoir quand les légumes vont
être prêts pour la récolte tous les
matins fait un tour des chats puis quand
on arrive à la réunion du matin dit déjà
sauf urgence à ses prêts ses fesses
c'est la sphère est vraiment au taquet
de des cultures
[Musique]
et malgré les défis ils retiennent le
positif que l'oise et de le tondre
d'autres cultures d'autres nationalités
habité partager le moment ensablement
dit ensemble ils travaillent à ça mais
c'est vraiment rare il nous place comme
sa commune un autre monde ici
un autre monde où il aimerait bien
s'enraciner on aime le québec
donc on aimerait bien habiter fit
longtemps que possible
[Musique]